hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the outlast 2 demo now I
believe this is the same demo that I
played in PAX East but I have this curse
or every time I play a game no matter
where I am I inevitably find a way to
break it and that happened when I was
playing this demo at PAX so sorry to the
developers and thank you developers for
getting me the demo but either way you
are Blake Langerman a Crammer man
working with your wife Lynn the two of
you are investing in inves to give
journalists willing to take risks and
dig deeper done to cover the stories no
one else would dare to touch you're
following a trail of clues this started
with the seemingly impossible murder of
a pregnant woman known only as Jane Doe
the investigation has led you miles into
the Arizona desert to a darkness so deep
that no one could shed light upon it and
a corruption so profound that going mad
maybe be the only sane thing to do ok so
I tell anyone ok two weeks ago
a young woman was found wandering
barefoot all right alone on a barren
stretch of highway a hundred miles from
the nearest
well yes I'm very very excited for this
the subtitles were a little off from the
audio there but that's okay I'm gonna
make sure the settings are all good
before I get started into the actual
game Lin oh there I am
oh boy now as far as my understanding
goes I don't think that this is the
character that we're gonna be playing
and actually outlast two of which I am
incredibly excited for because outlast
is just a shining gem in the horror game
genre I'm super happy that alone not
only that it existed but that it was
amazing and even the expansion or the
DLC or whatever you want to call it
whistleblower which was also very cool
so welcome back everybody welcome back
down last you all right buddy you'll
walk it off rub some dirt in it you'll
be fine
stitch up your broken leg with a few
sticks alright right mouse button a spur
huge and the night vision has returned
so we just had some sort of a plane
accident and this is the husband of the
wife Lynn that he's calling for and
that's all very you know not happy hello
hi I seem to be in a spot of trouble can
you help me please
even though ice here flies in there
somehow yeah probably dead bodies in
there I have an expert on knowing when
dead things are in places and I'm pretty
sure if i zoom in there that's probably
blood probably all right I'll leave you
alone you seem to be busy okay good bye
then
alright so like I said before I did play
this at PAX so I hi I don't know
if they've changed anything or updated
it since then I imagine they have
because I broke it
like I break everything in my life hello
oh that's a pleasant Oh
hey dead guy I'm whisper yelling thank
you sir have a lovely Hey
yeah that's so weird you can see the
Flies dusting around on his face there
just textures that they're bouncing
around him hello hi whoa goddammit stop
waving the flies away from my face now
in the demo I didn't take time to
explore so that's why I will try to do
oh so that's how it's gonna be a good
old-fashioned knocking fight is that
actually somebody on the other side of
that it's jammed hmm what a conundrum
were in oh I guess I'll venture on oh hi
what the hell hey how's it going there
who's who's there whoa this ain't good
what was that
huh say again I don't speak Spanish
all right oh hey hey oh don't run away
from me oh you got him a chat eh
alright bye buddy I didn't notice these
guys before is that Lynn well that's not
good
hello you have my wife it's good that
there it's good to know that there are
family people around here
what is that okay well I seem to be in
the thick of trouble okay so from what I
can interpret this and what I've seen
before there's like a commune or
something way back in the back areas
hello so you in there oh wow I honestly
didn't expect that to open okay
hi buddy how are you doing you in charge
you seem to have a halo but you don't
seem like the type of person that
deserving of a halo and I'll reload the
battery in a second I just want to make
sure that I get to absolutely everything
in there because I don't want to miss
out because I'm this is like the oh my
god what happened here oh go where's
there a spray no maybe I should hide in
the closet but I don't have time for
that we got to go we got places to be no
all right then [ __ ] that's
comforting okay let me just check this
door to open windows okay I don't think
that was there before or maybe it wasn't
I missed out on it I don't really know
probably did I apologize if I get some
scared by things that I got scared by
already such a big baby who's stepping
out there who's stepping okay move on
ooh that looks nice wait there was that
a door was that door slightly ajar it
was okay hello hi what's the point of
this threat oh there's no point okay
never mind then all right
let's get a move on you know I got a
good few places to be
okay Lin I'm coming for you
coming for you very slowly hi someone
just burped
there's someone burping in the woods
it's a boomer boomer is coming for us
satanís in a michael day i are you doing
nice slogan are you the three-eyed Raven
all right here we go
oh I remember this part oh this parts
bad
who is this parts bad okay so it took me
a while to fully comprehend what the
hell happened when I was playing the sit
packs but uh oof oof that's not a good
sign oof so notice the UH the this then
the blood whatever the hell this is
okay sacrifice them a new TIV that's a
lot of detail to put into this oh my god
list a pad all right
but this isn't the fucked-up part the
fucked-up parts over here oh it's bad
it's literally literally it's like I'm
not gonna lie I'm pretty sure that's a
pit of dead babies like it's rip this
game is going for [ __ ] up and it
reaches it and the worst part is you
gotta you gotta you out walk across it
cuz I know I know outlets has always
been about brutality
oh great symbolism here Oh with the well
I'm pretty sure I thought about this is
what I came over here
wait who said that who's talking
remember there being a voice before huh
I should look face-first into a well
whoa
maybe that's an intelligent decision to
making in town of Horrors here we go hey
I'll investigate this with my eyeballs
that habit
so that was a smoker that pulled me in
there there was a Boomer belching in the
woods and everything is going to [ __ ] so
somehow I don't know how
look behind left all alrighty there
no one's over there there's anybody over
there hello okay hi there who's there
don't let the the Thep the what wait man
I need to go this way please so am i
back off
we're all scared what'd you say I know
you said there don't blink I'm in the
vents
thank you very much I don't know why you
feel the need to talk to me little girl
so this is where things start to devolve
into madness oh I got a boo-boo oh yeah
I don't worry everything is in in
proportion wow that didn't look good all
right hello everybody
are you doing okay well that didn't open
well what am I supposed to do over here
this one okay there we go yeah that's
good that's that's a good I don't
remember the lights being out I thought
the lights were on last time I came here
okay so I made a mistake
when I was playing the demo in this area
I did something that I was not supposed
to do and I'm gonna do it again because
I think that's more interesting than
what then what what was supposedly
supposed to be done which would have
been intelligent opening doors Jana Rama
I'll pick up this weird music box
because that never hurts anybody in any
game ever oh hi hey Lin I'm so bored
yeah boy shut up [ __ ] oh geez all right
then why am I doing this so slowly okay
that wasn't creepy at all
oh geez whoa puss-ass oh hi oh this bad
my bad my bad
pry man probably bad thing I did or did
not do okay
I remember that being there before okay
what dafuq okay yeah that's the thing
see what you're supposed to do
apparently is hide cuz that would be
smart
but I ain't smart I'm the opposite of
smart I'm exactly unmarked I'm almost
out of batteries over here so I got a
move let's go go go
Oh weird light I'll step into you ah
good yes very nice all right
boop-boo-boo-boop alright so now we're
moving on this next area yeah what up I
can scream - oh no wait - peak I wish
I'd known about this why do so many of
these desks have clean up Kleenex sorry
tissue brand facial tissue wonder what's
going on over here hello that's always a
comforting sign ah
we're gonna [ __ ] was that ah yes good
very good
hi hello should I look up hi
take me with you no alright then I guess
I'm on my own huh wonder if there's
anything behind me oh well that's right
I got a run now
oh geez hi I didn't notice you before I
didn't notice a little ole god I'm stuck
I'm sorry here we go I'm probably gonna
die because I didn't get very much of a
head start now here is where I mean go
in the woods
uh-huh
okay I gotta go okay here this is what
this where I bugged out the game for
some reason this didn't work before
and for some reason oh I was only
running in the mo okay this is good
where am I going
Frick am I going over there [ __ ]
over there okay oh geez oh geez that
right back go faster I don't care if
you're tired so they're right by me
there we go safe at last
oh that was an adventure so yeah so yeah
that's why I don't think that's gonna be
the character that you play in outlast 2
but that's probably setting the scene
for the universe that they're in this
obviously isn't gonna be in the asylum
anymore they wanted to emphasize that
for the sequel but it looks phenomenal
it's so outlast definitely 100% it is
way outlast but it went from in the
first game cutting off a few fingers
which was bad to removing your entire
crotchal area that's no bueno no boy no
no boy you know so
I cannot wait for the final game to come
out it's going to be amazing if you want
to see the first outlast and the DLC
I'll put both in the annotations and the
description thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video professional
before I did you just two entrails of
the Fallen on your face